is the nhs app so this these this isn't
legally binding in the same way that if
someone's called up by an
nhs contact tracer they have to isolate
this is someone who's been in the
vicinity
and has therefore got this alert telling
them to self isolate but as you say
another record-breaking week so 689
000 people told to self-isolate in the
week ending last wednesday
the week before that the figure was just
under 620
000 so a significant increase we're
saying the number was down slightly in
wales but was up
significantly uh in england and
obviously this ties into the concern we
have seen around the so-called
pindemic the number of people being told
to self-isolate the impact that is
having
on businesses and on the workforce and
it ties into
with this issue around compliance and
there are separate figures out today
from the office for national statistics
that suggest that compliance
is coming down overall it is still high
but it is coming down particularly
among young people since may so people
aged between
18 and 34 uh one in four of those people
in that age
bracket have not been following those
self-isolation rules and we know
that this week the government revealed
their list of key workers that won't
have to follow self-isolation rules
in the same way we know that later on in
august those rules are going to be
scrapped all together but but as you say
another record-breaking week
and more than 680 000 people
told to self-isolate on the app within
the space of a week